have you started love island yet
yes dude okay i'm only on episode one or
two but i was crying laughing when the
girl gemma goes i'm gemma i'm 19. i
think that was like
what i was dying laughing what i was
[ __ ] around catching
i'm messing two dudes in the village and
one of them was like i like gemma she's
like a bit of me yeah what you mean what
do you like about her
actually just young
or like in spirit nor like numbers like
in age wait someone actually said that
no no oh you're just you're just like
yeah
it's just some dude being like she's a
teenager
oh what
i like that she's a teenager
yeah she's like young yeah there's a
there's a i mean i don't i don't want to
ruin it for you but it gets weird i'm
sure it does she's a daughter of some
like rich soccer player i guess some
famous soccer player even weirder well
and and people are pissed because like
they're making the show all about her oh
so not only is she like way younger
than anyone else on the show they're
trying to guess her up first they're
like she's the center of it yeah so
everyone's kind of like
did he like pay the produce how much
money did he put into this show or
something to
make his daughter famous basically
because
it's just turning into like the gemma
show it's really weird i would like to
make my teenage daughter very famous
there's like this niche joke that
sparked
and our other buddy of mine keep making
about like an off-brand mario brother
just named keith so then we're just just
saying like imagine him in the
one-on-ones or they're like maybe you
know my brother he had he's a race car
driver sometimes other times he like to
party and he fight a big dinosaur
he liked to jump on a mushroom
a very long time ago he fight a big
monkey
[Laughter]
that's hilarious a long time ago he
fight the big monkey
[Laughter]
he has saved a princess yeah you have a
fat [ __ ] he have a lot of experience
[Laughter]
he like a go-kart like eat a mushroom
gets big
you grow and nobody believed but
sometimes he put a fire from his mouth
yeah
give it what
you ever like to go in a pipe
he'll go down you go down the toilet and
kill the dinosaur yeah yeah
never mind i'm here to find a girlfriend
yeah i'm here to find my princess a
pizza
some dude steals her from him you're
like the big dinosaur i call my brother
he come to here and he kill you
you only need a mushroom and a fireball
[Laughter]
you jump on your head three times
you're dead
yeah man
yeah this new season is i was just
brother luigi yeah he does a fentanyl
what
we have a cass and his name is awario
wally
yeah
they get luigi addicted to fentanyl
oh that's sad i'm sorry to hear that
yeah he's really struggling
oh he always outside the castle like
bowser please give me a five dollar i
need to get a fentanyl now
you wear a green shirt
[Laughter]
oh
okay cool well
yeah no gemma's just sitting there like
yeah right that's nice
oh by the way she's a [ __ ] she's very
not nice she is she's so mean yeah she's
so mean [ __ ] you know what she
reminds me a lot of
me and kelsey is uh
uh veruca sour or whatever from
charlie the chocolate factory
dude the one the one dude oh you haven't
seen this far yet but i'll just ruin
this for you sure one of the guys just
leaves which
always seems to happen now yeah like the
first weeks ago it's like ah this is not
for me no he just was like yeah i'm not
really getting good vibes so i'm just
going to dip
dude is it i
yeah he's a nice guy i think his soul
got crushed because he's like none of
the girls were into him and when when
she gemma chose big man yeah he was like
a labrador in there he's like i just
want to see
what the vibe is maybe what you're
feeling yeah yeah it's like a little bit
too nice and then she's like
i think you should get stuck in an
elevator and it should fall down a
hundred stories and you should die and
he was like oh
right yeah no i like you too yeah yeah
yeah that's exactly what it is yeah so
i'm gonna leave
then he went in that pink jeep and just
drove it off the cliff
i searched it on twitter
like liam something love island and
someone was like i knew that dude was
gay
yeah
that's why he's leaving for sure yeah
mate you know what i just feel like
maybe i don't get along with any of the
girls here so i'm just gonna head out ha
i knew you were gay that guy likes penis
man for sure
i would love to be on that show but not
compete at all just like being in the
corner like talking about go-karts yeah
yeah distinctly smaller than everyone
else just like looking like a child no
would you like to go for a chat
no and i'm just like on the phone i'm
like sorry scusa world pro yeah it's
round four in utah give me a second
this is my phone just going
how do you have internet i didn't i
saved all these videos offline them
before i got to the villa so
oh that's cool no i worked out a deal
with the producers so that i get to
watch uh all go-kart racing yeah
internationally we're
wearing like just beats the whole time
yeah yeah you're always canceling it
just i don't want to go
i'm just
just grown ipad kid bro
what
do you want to go for a chat oh no
i just make it to the end
because just as the friend couple yeah
well no like he hasn't like he doesn't
say much but like he's quite nice and
he's okay to sleep with
i'm just under a blanket in the [ __ ]
living room
pillow wall yeah you and the girl
all right this is my side that's your
side don't come on my side
or i'm going to be really mad
full face sleeping mask
with just a hole for the mouth sleep
apnea yeah yeah cpap
machine no mate do you mind turning that
off i will die
light goes on in the morning how'd you
all sleep uh samantha was farting the
whole night
he's getting in my cpap machine i could
just i couldn't stop
smelling her musty farts did you have a
good sleep did you guys have a little
cuddle no she was farting the whole
night
she stunk even or just something like
i would have liked to but her breath
stinks from the fish we ate last night
i don't think she brushes her teeth i'll
brush my teeth not hard enough
that's what it's going to be if they
keep casting younger younger people
just a 10 year old
just kept imagining this image of like
all these hot stupid people being like
oh you won't fall in the mirror and just
in the corner some guy just
[Laughter]
you